[Musique]
bonjour
11 2
qu'est ce qui t'a plu chez lui
qu'est-ce qui va plus chez lui rien mais
toi qui se tape une chandelle
pareil pour moi c'est une femme c'est
l'intérieur tiens c'est pas l'extérieur
et si bien qu'elles n'ont ils pas cela
équipage je saute dessus obligé bah
ouais bah oui obligé vous avez pas du
tout âge je regarde ses fesses à part ça
qu'est ce qui vous plaît chez une fille
j'ai pas le temps là c'est plutôt
l'aspect intellectuel plutôt que
l'aspect physique
résultat plus chez elle à tout ça
s'explique pas la même chose si j'en ai
plusieurs c'est parce que j'aime bien
découvrir quelque chose chez plusieurs
nana comme ça mais je tends la spa
puisque katherine et joe
non mais enfin fait que j'ai faim la
renommée toujours de quoi c'est at il
dit s'étonnant ses deux copines les
pieds ses yeux et spiritualité son
sourire
pas grand-chose sont homosexuels donc
gentillesse sa protection
la fidélité le public d'abord les
physique ça joue mais ça joue dans un
premier temps et ensuite si ça suffit
pas intellectuellement sont pas marché
c'est on met en place de puits lâche
qu'ont longtemps et puis tout d'un coup
pourtant on n'a pas beaucoup de choses
en commun mais elle est superbe et
péladeau ont pas dit c'est le bon c'est
celui-là ça sera ma vie on clame
complètement après
voilà donc moi je plane depuis trois
jours qu'est ce qui t'attire chez une
fille la nuque
pardon la nuque
les gars qu au ce qui t'attire chez une
fille
1 on va
déjà six en pâtit et puis à
mais la beauté bien sûr parce que autour
[Musique]